hello I'm going to talk about comparison
operators and if-else statements first
of all let's look at some code here we
have R is FCC great and I've set this
variable here's how we declare a
variable here's the name of the variable
we've set that to be equal to true so
now look this is the if statement down
here if and then in parentheses we put
something that we're testing we're just
gonna put this variable which we've set
to true so if whatever's in here which
we have as is FCC great if this is true
we are going to do whatever is in these
brackets so what's in this brackets is
console dot log free code camp is
amazing so if we run that it is going to
say free code camp is amazing however if
we change this to false and we I'm gonna
clear the console and run that again
it's not gonna do anything because since
this is false it's not going to do
what's in the brackets but to be able to
see that better I'm going to end else so
else so let me just copy this I'm gonna
paste it down here and put for a ball
and we're gonna run that so if this is
true it's gonna do within the first
brackets but when we get else else means
if it's false it's going to do within
the 2nd brackets
however we better change this back to
true before Quincy sees it and they're
there that's what it should say free
code camp is amazing ok now I'm going to
talk about comparison operators
comparison operators are more than less
than less than or equal to more than or
equal to equals equals which just means
equals or not equals the less than or
more than symbols the way I remember
which one is which is if you see the
less than symbol kind of looks like the
letter L the less than symbol opens the
same direction as a capital L which is
the first letter in the word less than
so let's put some code here to test
these out
all right put 8 equals 18 and if age is
greater than or equal to 18 so if it's
18 or any number more than 18 we're
gonna console that log you were an adult
let me run that and it says you were an
adult now this is where we can use some
some else if statements that's a new
thing I want to show you else
if now before it's either two things
it's either doing one thing or we're
doing the other thing but else if we're
gonna do something if age is more than
equal to 18 else if now this may not
always happen depending on what's in the
the parentheses for the if we're gonna
say a is less than 18 and I'm just going
to copy this up here you are a child if
we if we run this it's just gonna be
pretty so much it's gonna say you are
adults but if I change this to one and
we run that it's gonna say you were a
child
let's try it put another thing in here
else if
so we're gonna say else if age is less
than to console dot log you are a baby
and this is gonna give me a good chance
to show you something else if I click
run it's gonna say you were a child it's
not gonna say you were a baby even
though the age is one the age in less
than two but it's not saying you were a
baby because once the program evaluates
one of these it stops evaluating so look
at this else if age is less than 18
console that long you were a child now
that this has been evaluated it's just
not going to even check any of the other
items so it's not even a check this
that's why it can be very important to
order you put things so for this example
we probably want to put this up here I'm
just copying and pasting here and now
we're gonna check about the aging less
than two first and then check if the age
is less than 18 and that should do more
of what we're trying to get at here and
now what it's gonna say you were a baby
if we change the stick 10 it's gonna say
let's see you are a child and it's still
gonna say and say anything above 18 it's
going to say you want alt so let's check
a few more things we're going to show
that equal equals and the not equals and
change this to 18 and we're gonna try
that we're gonna run that you are 18 so
it says if 8 equals equals 18 console
that log you are 18 so the important
thing about this is that to check if
something is equal you always use two
equal signs because if you only use one
equal sign
that's an assignment operator and now we
are going to set the variable age to be
equal to 18 instead of checking to see
if age does equal 18 now something
interesting about that is that it's
still gonna put true because whenever
you set a variable equal to a number
it's always going to evaluate is true
but now later in the program if if we
have it started at 10
and then we're gonna have set 18 now age
is going to equal 18 so you want to make
sure you always use two equal signs
that's how you test if something is
equal there's also a comparison operated
with three equal signs equals equals
equals I'm going to talk about that in a
future video for now the last one I want
to show you is the not equal so if you
put the exclamation point right before
word if age does not equal 18 we're
gonna say you are not 18 let me clear
the console we're gonna run that and
it's gonna say you are not 18 okay well
those are if and else statements and
computers and operators thanks for
watching my name is beau Carnes check
the description for links to more
information don't forget to subscribe
and remember use your code for good